well thank you all for coming to my talk
this morning today I'm going to be
talking about using get metadata to
predict code bug risk we've already done
the introduction so we can skip that so
the over the kind of broad outline of
how this talk is going to go is I'm
going to start with a brief introduction
to get and some of the metadata that it
collects for you and then in the bulk of
the talk I'll go over how we use that
metadata to build the model to predict
code bug risk and then finally at the
end I'll finish up with a few tips you
can use to improve your own get usage so
first of all show of hands how many of
you have heard of git before okay
how many of you use git okay so we can
go through the introduction pretty quick
then so first of all git is a version
control tool but you already know that
because you all use it so I think the
more relevant point on this slide is the
xkcd comic on the left which highlights
the fact that most people who use git do
so at a kind of surface level a lot of
times you memorize a couple commands
like this is how I add my files this is
how I make a commit and that's about all
you do with git and if things break then
you blow it all up and start over so
what I'm gonna argue today is that if
you go a little bit deeper into get and
learn about some of the other stuff that
is doing under the hood it's actually a
really powerful tool and in particular
it can be a source of really infamous
really interesting information about
both the history of your codebase and
your coding practices in general so
that's kind of the the main point I'm
trying to make here is git is really
powerful and if you do a little if you
go a little bit deeper than your just
get add get commit commands you can get
a lot of interesting information out of
it
the primary unit in git is the git
commit so this is one unit of change and
a couple things about git commits are
particularly relevant for this talk the
first is that each commit gets its own
you
unique identifier so every every commit
you can go back and find that commit by
using that unique identifier and second
each individual commit gets a lot of
metadata associated with it so things
like when the commit was made who made
it what is actually included in the
commit when I talk about using get
metadata this is the metadata that I'm
talking about all of the information
that is associated with each individual
commit in your history so if that's the
metadata if that's the the raw material
that we want to be using here how do we
go about getting at it well there are
three main tools that we're going to be
using in this process three different
get sub commands the first of these is
git log git log shows you the history of
changes to your project so it shows you
all of the commits that have been made
to your project over the course of its
lifetime and different arguments to get
log can expose different parts of that
metadata so you can for example just
show the commit message or you can show
a little bit more like which files were
modified or who made the change so for
example a simple version might look like
this where you call git log with some
arguments and you just get out the
commit identifier is over here and the
message associated with each commit so
this is a simple just kind of way to
look through and see all the changes
that happen and the descriptions of each
change you can also use some different
arguments and get a little bit more
detailed information so here it's a
different get log call that shows in
addition to the identifier things like
who made it when did they make it what
is the line so git log is tool number
one and that's going to be our main
workhorse for getting at all of this
metadata but there are a couple others
that are also particularly useful number
two is get diff what get diff does is
you give it to different commit
identifiers to different IDs and it will
show you all of the changes that
occurred between those two commits so
you can give it one point in history and
another point in history and see all of
the things that have changed within your
code base between those two things so
this is an example of what a git diff
output might look like you get the file
name you get the logs and then you get
to see that these lines with the pluses
all got added between these two commits
so git log get diff and then the last
one is get blame what get blame does is
you pass in a file and it will tell you
for every line of code in that file what
was the blast commit which modified that
particular line so this is an example
output and over here on the left you can
see the commit identifier z' and then
the line number and then the actual code
so for each line of code you can go back
in and say what what commit most
recently modified this particular file
so these these three git commands are
going to be the main tools that we're
working with here git log to get out a
whole bunch of metadata get diff to see
what kind of changes are being
introduced and get blame to see what was
the last commit that modified a
particular line so that's our whirlwind
tour of git since you've all used it
already so next we get to the meat of
the talk which is using this metadata to
build a model of code bug risk and this
is generally a four step process so step
number one we need to identify and label
which commits in the history of our
codebase introduced a bug we're trying
to build a model here we're trying to
build a binary classifier so we need
some labels so step one is going to be
using git metadata trackback and figure
out these labels figure out which
commits introduced bugs in the first
place step two is build features for
each commit so we're building a model we
need labels and features step one is get
the labels step two is get the features
step three is to actually train our
model train our binary classifier
spoiler alert this is the easiest step
kind of par for the course in machine
learning
percent of the work is getting all your
features and labels and then finally in
step four we're going to use one last
little bit of git trickery to set this
up so that our model automatically runs
and scores every new commit we make to
the repository so that's kind of the the
four step overview of how this model
gets built
step one is particularly involved so
we're going to go through that kind of a
piece by piece so the main idea here is
to what we're trying to do is assign
labels figure out which commits
introduced a bug in the first place and
we do that with these four steps here so
first we find all the commits that are
tagged with a message that includes the
word bug or fix so here what we're
trying to do is find all the changes we
made to the codebase which were to
correct a bug these are bug fixes once
we found those bug fixes for each of
those commits we want to go in and see
which lines of code that bug fix was
changing so we find our bug fixes and
then for each of them go in see what
lines that bug fix changed and do that
with git diff then once we know what
files and what lines that change we use
git blame to find the previous commit
that modified those lines that are
getting fixed by the bug fix and we
label that previous commit as having
introduced a bug that is being fixed by
hour later bug fix commit so one more
time from the top what we're doing is
we're looking for bug fixes seeing what
they changed finding what last modified
that thing that they're fixing and
saying the last thing to touch that was
what introduced the bug in the first
place now this comes with a big caveat
that all of this only works if you have
very good commit hygiene so what commit
hygiene is is the idea that each of your
commits should only do one particular
thing so if I have a bug fix commit a
commit that I've labeled as fixing a bug
it should only have changes that are
related to fixing that bug if
bug-fix commit fixes that bug but also
changes a couple things over here and
tidies up some back strings that i
noticed we're bad while I was doing this
then this is going to throw off this
whole approach because all of those
other changes will get us treated as
part of the bug and incorrectly labeled
as a bug fix so one every commit should
really only be doing one thing and
number two your commit messages should
be meaningful and standardized there's
there can be a tendency for commit
messages to get sloppy as you go through
bug fixes they start out fixing bug in
the labeling thing and turn into that
didn't work try again and then up and
then goddammit and then so on so you
really need your commit messages to
accurately describe what you're doing at
the end of this talk I'll go over a
couple tips for improving your own
commit hygiene because even if you're
not doing this kind of modeling exercise
it's a useful practice to follow but for
the time being
bear in mind that all this really relies
on this good commit hygiene so walking
through each of these labeling steps now
first we want to find commits which fix
bugs so we're gonna do that with this
git log
command right here git log and we tell
it to grep to search for bug and for fix
and we pass the - I to make it case
insensitive we tell it to pretty print
things on one line because all we really
care about is the commit message and
we're also going to tell it to
abbreviate the commit just so it's
easier to parse so this will chop the
commit identifier down to eight
characters so at this point we have a
big long list of commits which are
fixing bugs the next step is for each of
those commits when I go in and find what
lines and what files that commit changed
and to do that we're going to use this
get diff command so we have some hash we
have some ID for a commit and we're
going to use a little bit of git syntax
here which is this caret what the caret
is saying is tell me about the commit
right before this one so if we read this
git command kind of semantically it's
saying tell me the difference between
the commit right before this
- and in this actual hash so saying
essentially what are the changes only
introduced by this one commit does that
all make sense looking like one back
from where we are now
and finally the you zero is just saying
only show me the lines that were
actually changed in the commit when you
normally run git diff it'll give you a
little bit on either side just so you
have some context around the change but
in this case we only want the thing that
was actually changed that's the last new
zero so that'll get you something that
looks like this do see the file name
shows you the code and in particular in
between these double @ signs it'll tell
you the lines that were changed so this
is what I'm trying to get out of this
step I want to know the file that was
changed and the lines within that file
so moving on once we have that now we
can use git blame to look back in time
and see what was the previous commit to
modify that line before our bug fix and
that command looks like this so we get
blame we pointed at the file that we
care about again we're saying tell me
about the point in history right before
my bug fix so it's that same little
caret syntax and then - L the start line
in the stop line so this is saying tell
me who is to blame for every line in
this file as of right before my bug fix
and especially these particular lines so
an example here I have before and after
applying the bug fix commit after the
commit is applied you can see that line
187 has a different commit identifier
over here but if we look back to before
the bug fix was applied we can see the
commit hash the ID of the commit that
introduced that change in the first
place this is where we're trying to get
to this whole time because now we know
that commit to 54 e whatever whatever is
the one that introduced the change in
the first place that our bug fix is now
correcting so we can label commit to 54
e whatever as a 1 this is a commit that
introduced a bug so that whole process
is kind of involved you definitely don't
wanna do it by hand but fortunately it's
very easy to automate that with a bunch
of pie
fun in particular you can use sub
process check output and then just pass
in your get commands as a string and
that will get you back the response as a
string you do a little Python string
processing some regular expressions and
whatnot and you can repeat that whole
process for the entire commit history of
your project of your whole repository so
you can go through for every commit in
your history and label it a 1 or a 0 by
whether or not it introduced a bug ok
that was step one but that was the hard
step so from here on out is smoother
sailing step two we want to build
features for each of those commits so we
have the labels now we need to build the
features and in this case get log is
going to be our workhorse in particular
get log with the dash dash stat option
because that gives you an output that
looks like this over here and right off
the bat there are a couple obvious
choices or a couple obvious things you
can use as features so for example how
many files did this commit change that
might be an interesting feature
how many insertions how many new lines
of code to this edge how many deletions
how many lines did this take out with a
little bit of creativity you can also
think of for example how long is the
commit message if you tag your commit
messages you could build a categorical
feature on whether it's an enhancement
or a bug fix or a refactor or something
like that did this work happen on the
weekend did this work happen after 11:00
p.m. all these kind of things you could
make and if you really want to make
friends you could build a commit a
commit or a feature on who made it but
use at your own risk
so anyway step 2 got our features step 3
again it's the easy one in this case we
used a random forest classifier built a
model on these features and labels and
it kind of works so we get an AUC of
0.76 which is really not that bad we can
look at some of the feature importances
in just a simple simple model length of
the commit message shows up on top for
most predictive
additions deletions time actually does
turn out to be kind of predictive here
so yeah this once you've done all the
work to build up your labels and build
up your features building the model kind
of works but here I'm gonna rain on the
parade a little bit and repeat the
caveat that this really absolutely
requires that you have really good
commit hygiene so the example I'm
showing here is from running this on
kind of our most pristine internal
repository and trying it on things where
this the coding standard and the process
standard is a little bit lower really
degrades a performance one in terms of
model and two in terms of how much you
should trust the model like being able
to duplicate the labels if the labels
aren't meaningful isn't particularly
useful so big warning this really really
requires good commit hygiene and then
the last step is to hook this up so that
it runs automatically every time you
make a new commit and to do this we're
going to use one last little bit of git
which is called git hooks so git hooks
are scripts that run automatically every
time you take a particular get action so
for example you could have a pre-commit
hook that runs before like you're trying
to make a new kit new commit but before
we get saved before it gets recorded
this pre-commit hook script will run
there's another one for commit message
which every time you try to save a
commit message that hook will run and
but one that we care about is the post
commit hook so every time you make a new
commit and record it this post commit
hook script will run so what you can do
is make a simple little Python script
put it in your project dot git slash
hooks and a file called post commit and
this file will run every time you make a
new commit so what you can do is pull in
a few packages check the output of your
latest get log call the - - one means
only tell me about the most recent one
commit do whatever feature parsing you
did in the first place to generate your
model load up your pickled model and
predict on the features of your most
so big drumroll the final output of all
this is something that looks like this
you make a new commit and you get a
little thing that says this is how risky
this particular commit is so that's kind
of the the bulk of the talk that that
concludes the modeling portion but
before I wrap up and open up for
questions I want to quickly run through
a couple things you can do on your own
to improve your commit hygiene not just
because you might want to do this kind
of modeling exercise but because it's
useful in general so I say it's useful
in general why is that the case well
number one clean commit histories can
help you understand the evolution of a
codebase say you go on vacation for two
weeks you come back you want to see what
happened if your colleagues use good
commit hygiene you can just pull up the
repository see the messages see what's
been changed see what's been worked on
at a glance see what's going on in the
codebase that's very handy number two
maybe even more handy if you have good
commit hygiene every single line of code
in your codebase is documented because
if you come up on a block of code that
you don't understand and there's no
inline comment you can pull up you can
like get blamed see what commits
introduced that get logs go find those
commits go find every commit that touch
those lines and see what introduced it
how did it get changed why did it get
changed and you can do that for every
single line in your codebase if you have
good commit hygiene and finally it's not
that hard git has a couple tools that
make it even easier so I'll go over
those real quick and then we'll be done
first of all there's that commit message
hook that I mentioned before this runs
every time you try to save a commit
message so you can do some very simple
checking here just make sure the commit
messages is of a certain length not just
fix or bug or damn it
you can also enforce standards around
tags so if you use tags for your commits
and your repositories for like a bug a
test of work in progress things like
that you can automatically reject
commits that don't include that tag in
their commit message so that's one easy
step what about the situation where
you've gotten carried away and made a
whole bunch of edits to one particular
file that aren't all necessarily related
to the same thing well get add has this
handy patch
option which lets you independently
select edits to a file and add them in
separate commits so what it does is you
get added with this patch flag and it
will present you each little block of
changes that you've made and you can
choose whether or not you want to add
that particular block of changes so
that's pretty handy and finally what if
you've already made a whole bunch of
messy commits well in this case the
interactive rebase is your friend
so what interactive rebase lets you do
is go back and edit your commit history
you can take individual commits and
break them up you can combine previous
commits into one bigger one if you have
lots of little things that are all doing
the same general tasks you can change
commit messages all that kind of stuff
git rebase is super powerful but I will
end with one warning which is you should
only rebase code that other people
haven't seen yet if you're just working
on your own branch your own fork rebased
your heart's content but once other
people have started working off your
code you shouldn't be rebasing rebase is
its own thing so I won't get into any
more than that I think that's time
anyway so with that thank you for your
attention and open up for questions
[Applause]
yeah modeling for your excuse me did you
run any modeling for your feature
selections I know you're making that
joke about whether you want to pick the
person or the feature but no so this
this is kind of in the proof-of-concept
stage so we haven't done any elaborate
feature engineering or model tuning or
anything like that it was really just
kind of see if this works staged the
question was did I ever use git bisect
to be more accurate about where the book
came from
no I didn't could you modify your
approach to handle bugs that are
introduced over a series of commits
especially when it's complex piece of
code I think that would be kind of hard
to do because of this the way we're
actually doing in the labeling in the
first place
so that is a that's a fair point and
that's definitely a limitation of the
approach as it is here have you
experimented with tools that are
integrating with tools that measure test
coverage can you say a little bit more
about what kind of integration you're
you mean I'm sure thinking of a tool
like code cuff that will tell you which
lines of a file are covered by a unit
test I hadn't considered doing that can
you say something about model
interpretability so your number one
feature was length of the commit message
does that mean it's an unusually short
commit messages or unusually long commit
messages that cause the problem yeah
it's so we're using a random forest so
we can't automatically infer
directionality from the future we had a
couple competing internal hypotheses one
was that long commit messages mean
complicated changes which are more
likely to introduce bugs the other was
that short commit messages were proxies
for kind of cowboy coding so with a
little more work you could dive into
that question but that's kind of the
general answer for model inter
credibility if you have a random forest
you need to go do other things and just
look at the feature importances yeah
that does seem like a reasonable
interpretation have you done any testing
on this model on a different project to
see how you know generalizes so how it
transferrable the model is yeah I didn't
try taking the same trained model and
applying it on different different code
bases we did give a little thought to
within the feature engineering you could
have kind of project specific features
if there's one project to really care
about so you know problematic like you
know one file has a lot of the
complicated logic you could just have a
binary on was that file modified but we
didn't try taking a trained model from
one project and porting it over to
another project do you know how many bug
fix commits we would need before we
would get to see these numbers results
from this or how many you had in your
project uh so this project had order a
thousand commits or so and I want to say
there were 100 order a hundred bucks
IX's I can't really give you like that's
my only data point we tried around this
and this is what we got with this I'm
not sure how it would perform if you
tried it on sparse your data we have
time for one more question anybody else
no okay Thank You Henry thank you
[Applause]